making the Revenant was about man's
relationship to the natural world a
world that we collectively felt in 2015
as the hottest year in recorded history
our production needed to move to the
southern tip of this planet just to be
able to find snow climate change is real
it is happening right now
it is the most urgent threat facing our
entire species and and we need to work
collectively together and stop
procrastinating we need to support
leaders around the world who do not
speak for the big polluters of the big
corporations but who speak for all of
humanity for the indigenous people of
the world for the billions and billions
of underprivileged people who will be
most affected by this for our children's
children and for those people out there
whose voices have been drowned out by
the politics of greed I thank you all
for this amazing award tonight let us
not take this planet for granted I do
not take tonight for granted thank you
so very much